for 24 years this statue stood inside
the campus of hong kong university the
harrod twisted figures a memorial to the
tiananmen square protesters of 1989 who
asked for more freedom and who got
bullets in return in mainland china even
discussing the topic is taboo but hong
kong was a place where people could
remember and the pillar of shame did not
just honor the past but stood tall as
proof of hong kong's unique freedoms its
difference from other chinese cities
these days things are not so different
though under the cover of darkness they
took it down
the pillar was covered up and put into
storage
the next day onlookers could see the new
meaning in the now empty space
i don't think people would expect this
thing would happen in
the university so caught with
the most freedom of expression or
freedom of speech
and
they tried to become the first one to
remove every history or parts of history
inside the campus
yet
the university council said it had
removed the statute based on external
legal advice and risk assessment for the
best interest of the university
the pillar sculptor vowed to fight the
decision this is my sculpture and it's
my property so in the moment they are
destroying
artwork who belong to a foreign artist
and i think
maybe this is a new case and of course
we will try to protect our property in
hong kong and
even soon if this this is necessary the
room for descent is shrinking in hong
kong ever since beijing imposed a
sweeping national security law the
plastic boards the empty space are their
own monument to the change
tom cheshire sky news beijing